feldkirchen herzen kommen zu einem neuen
video und ihre leute ich war letztens
auf youtube unterwegs hab mich ein
bisschen umgeschaut hat geguckt was
gerade passiert was gerade aktuell so
abgehen auf der plattform natürlich habe
ich auch noch bei den üblichen
verdächtigen vorbeischaut eine upgrade
your mother selbstverständlich da war
nicht aber die gefahr dass draußen
gehauen fast mich einfach mal wieder
komplett vom hocker gehauen heißt dass
man sowas einfache hochladen kann
die optimierte schon bis heute aber geht
um das video und styling mit meinem
vater und das ist aus verschiedenen
gründen unter anderem wegen denen die in
ihrem titel gesehen hat nämlich
schleichwerbung
ich bin ja politik erkennen könnt habe
ich mir etwas unnormales krankes
überlegt und zwar eine kombination die
zum schluss noch nicht gab und sein
umfeld wieder mit man muss an der stelle
einfach würdigen welche gedankliche
leistung dahinter steckt dieses video
erfunden wurde wer hätte bedeutet wer
hätte nach dem video um styling mit
meiner schwester aufkommen köln dass man
irgendwann umstellung mit seinem vater
macht bisher vollkommen abwegig oder
schwester vater irgendwann kann diese
fragen sich natürlich woher hat dieser
spaßreligion hier von meinem daddy wir
sehen können sie sich überhaupt eine
phase eingehen weil ich muss mal kurz
was sagen müssten meinung habt seid mal
ehrlich wenn mich ein witz macht da
denkt man doch betrieb ist geist
irgendwie ganz gesund ja ich würde sagen
gefordert wieder losgeht wollte ich noch
ne coole apps vorstellen und zwar
trainee bei dem moduswechsel vorhersagen
können
heute in place modus sind die muskeln
eine bibel umschreiben wieder auf play
damit waren sie denn mal effekten
sensoren meines beiden sozusagen die auf
jeden fall aus immer wenn youtube
amazone vorstellen von ecolab gegner
gefunden haben dann sollte man hellhörig
werden genau den sound und deutlich vor
allen dingen darauf schauen ob das was
wahrscheinlich werbung ist so wie in dem
verliere ganz klar währung auch
gekennzeichnet ist herrschen deutschland
die meinung dass produktplatzierung
sowie in dem fall wenn sie bezahlt sind
als werbung gekennzeichnet werden müssen
sondern nämlich schleichwerbung und
fleisch werbung ist doof ist wissen wir
alle
außerhalb die gefahren klar wenn ich
dich dann erblich deuten wenn man so was
macht eine operation muss am anfang und
am ende des videos zumindest oben rechts
produktplatzierung stehen oder für vier
oder fünf sekunden am anfang und am ende
oder aber wenn sich das ganze video um
diese effekte drehen da muss durchgehend
werbevideo dasteht
wir können ja einfach nummer so einfach
als pflichtübung wieder einen anfang
kippen umschauen
auch miguel partner das vielleicht doch
richtig gekennzeichnet hat muss ich ihn
nicht gleich alles was geht ich bin
nicht ratlos und willkommen für einen
neuen video von mir produktplatzierung
an dieser stelle nicht das ist eine
etwaige letzter zeit sehr hart wird auch
bei youtube also was sagen ja jetzt
persönlich mega auf tendenziell auch
immer bitten vorsichtig ich bin euch
hier jetzt noch mal ein video von der
leyen auf jeden fall ein
gesichtsausdruck achten wenn sie daran
zu erkennen wie sehr sie davon überzeugt
dass ich alle sagen i gotta william o
mat.de f die macht folglich spiel die
app jeden tag auf gar keinen fall
irgendein scheitert oder verlogen
darüber zdf spielt auf keinen fall jetzt
sagen moment mal 16 bietet die hat
einfach wirklich gerne möchte einfach
aus patrick gewinnspiel dafür machen und
etwas verloren leider funktioniert die
welt nicht noch mehr service kanal der
macht nur 300 mit 400.000 autos pro
video und da kann man einfach mal keine
unrealistische zahl sehen bis 15.000
euro vielleicht für ein video nehmen
einfach ein video die mein produkt
vorstellt je nachdem was ich gesagt habe
überlegt euch mal hat der farbe gleich
1000 euro bekommen dafür dass er die app
so kritisch stumpf und ein video
integriert und lauren gewinnt gemacht
oder hat er einfach diesen super coole
und tollem vor kurzem entdeckt spielt er
auf jeden fall höchsten anteil hat
überhaupt geld dafür bekommen
der überlegene stellung für mich zu weit
aus dem fenster lehnen will gibt es
davon aus dass hier um schleichwerbung
handels bestimmt dafür geld bekommen
gerade wenn er sagt ihr macht noch nicht
gewinnspiel die frage wir wissen dass
irgendwie nicht so solltet aber was kann
eigentlich wirklich passiert theoretisch
kann das passieren was nämlich dass da
eine sogenannte landesmedienanstalt für
die aufsicht über gewissen wenn ich
zuständig sei aktiv wird und wie gesagt
die scheiße lässt er das gerne machen
und wenn die gefahr dass sich nicht
erheben wahrscheinlich auch mit einem
bußgeld war die kundin 5000 euro oder
umgebucht und es potenziell auch
durchgesetzt wie findest du dich ja egal
dass wir möglichst natürlich ist ein
vater aus natürlich sehr überzeugt von
diesem video hat auf jeden fall braucht
nicht in die wertung dabei was auch die
reaktion des westens bewegt die soziale
kompetenz meiner leitung einfach ein
bisschen auf dieses schleich
währungsthema auch von zu machen und
natürlich auch ich mache mich aber gerne
über andere gut erhaltenes rausgewählt
viele leute hier umkehren könnte wodurch
war jacko regierung geht schon was
mitgliedern könnten einfach auf der
straße tabu mit verschiedenen leuten
gibt nur 2006 zum nächsten video